the convolution operation is one of the
fundamental building blocks of a
convolutional neural network using edge
detection as the motivating example in
this video you see how the convolution
operation works in previous videos have
talked about how the early layers of the
neural network might detect edges and
then the summer later layers might
detect positive objects and then even
later layers may be to take parts of
complete objects like people's faces in
this case in this video you see how you
can detect edges in an image let's take
an example given a picture like that for
a computer to figure out what are the
objects in this picture the first thing
you might do is maybe detect vertical
edges in this image so for example this
image has all those vertical lines where
the railings are as was you know kind of
vertical lines idea online movies
pedestrians and so those get detected in
this vertical edge detector output and
you might also want to detect horizontal
edges so for example there's a very
strong horizontal line where this
railing is and that also gets detected
sort of roughly here so how do you
detect edges in an image like this let's
look at an example here is a six by six
grayscale image and because this is a
grayscale image this is just a six by
six by one matrix rather than six by six
by three because they're on separate RGB
channels in order to detect edges or
let's say vertical edges in this image
what you can do is construct a three by
three matrix and in the pollens when the
terminology of convolutional neural
networks this is going to be called a
filter and I'm going to construct a
three by three filter or feareth II
matrix that looks like this 1 1 1 0 0 0
minus 1 minus 1 minus 1
sometimes research papers would call
this a colonel instead of a filter but
I'm going to use the filter terminology
in these videos and what you're going to
do is take the 6x6 image and convolve it
and the convolution operation is denoted
by this asterisk in convolve it with the
3x3 filter one slightly unfortunate
thing about the notation is that in
mathematics the asterisk is the standard
symbol for convolution but in Python
this is also used to denote
multiplication or maybe element-wise
multiplication so this asteroids has
dual purposes it's overloaded notation
but I'll try to be clear in these videos
when this asterisks refers to
convolution and the output of this
convolution operator will be a four by
four matrix which you can interpret that
which you can think of as a four by four
image and the way you compute this four
by four output is as follows to compute
the first element the upper-left element
of this four by four matrix we're going
to do is take the three by three filter
and paste it on top of the three by
three region of your original input
image so I've written here 1 1 1 0 0 0
minus 1 minus 1 minus 1 and what you
should do is take the element wise
product so the first one would be 3
times 1 and then the second one would be
1 times 1 I'm going down here 1 times 1
and then plus 2 times 1 this one and
then add up all of the resulting 9
numbers so then the middle column gives
you 0 plus times 0 plus 5 times 0 4 7
times 0 and then the rightmost column
gives 1 times minus 1 8 times minus 1
plus 2 times minus 1 and adding up these
9 numbers will give you negative 5 and
so I'm going to fill in negative 5 over
here ok and you can add
these nine numbers in any order of
course it's just that I went down the
first roll dinner it's just I went down
the first column then the second column
then the third next to figure out what
is this second element you're gonna take
the blue square and shift it one step to
the right like so and let me get rid of
the green moths here and you're going to
do the same element wise product and
then addition so you have 0 times 1 plus
5 times 1 plus 7 times 1 plus 1 times 0
plus 8 times 0 plus 2 times 0 plus 2
times negative 1 plus 9 times negative 1
plus 5 times negative 1 and if you add
up those 9 numbers you end up with
negative 4 and so on if you ship this to
the right do the 9 products and add them
up you get 0 and then over here you
should get faint right then just to
verify you have 2 plus 9 plus 5 that's
16 then the middle column gives you 0
and then the rightmost column 4 plus 1
plus 3 times negative 1 that's minus 8
so that's 16 on the left column minus 8
and that gives you ain't right like we
have over here next in order to get you
this element in the next row what you do
is take the blue square and now shift it
one down so you now have it in that
position and again repeat the
element-wise product and then adding
exercise and if you do that you should
get negative 10 here and they'd be
shifted one to the right you should get
negative 2 and then 2 and then 3 and so
on um - then throw in all the rest of
the elements of the matrix and so to be
clear this minus 16 would be obtained by
you know from this lower right feedback
through region
so a 6x6 matrix involved with a 3x3
matrix gives you a 4x4 matrix and these
are images and filters these are really
just matrices of various dimensions but
the matrix on the left is convenient to
interpret as a image and the one in the
middle we interpret as a filter and the
one on the right you can interpret that
this may be another image and this turns
out to be a vertical edge detector and
you see why on the next line before
going on though just one other comment
which is that if you implement this in a
programming language then in practice
most premier languages will have some
different function rather than an
asterisk to denote convolution so for
example in the program exercise you use
or you implement a function called cond
forward if you do this intensive flow
there's a function T f dot n n dot conf
2d you know and then other people
earning programming frameworks in the
carrots purring framework which you see
later in this course there's a function
called conf 2d to implement convolution
and so on but all the deep learning
frameworks that have good support for
computer vision will have you know some
function for implementing this
convolution operator so why is this
doing vertical edge detection let's look
at another example
so the illustrator is we're going to use
a simplified image so here is a simple
six by six image where the left half of
the image is 10 and the right half is 0
if you're caught this is a picture it
might look like this where the left half
the tens give you brighter pixel
intensity values and the right half
gives you darker pixel intensity values
I'm using that shade of gray to denote
zeros although maybe it could also be a
draw this black but in this image
there's clearly a very strong vertical
edge right down the middle of this image
as it transitions from white to black or
white to darker color
so when you convolve this with the 3x3
filter and so this 3x3 filter can be
visualized as follows where is lighter
brighter pixels on the left and then
this mid-tone zeroes in the middle and
in darker on the right what you get is
this matrix on the right so just to
verify this NAFA you want this is 0 for
example is obtained by taking the
element wise products and then
multiplying with this 3x3 block and so
you get from the left column 10 plus 10
plus 10 and then zeros in the middle and
then minus 10 minus 10 minus 10 which
why you end up with 0 over here whereas
in contrast if that 30 will be obtained
from this which you get from having you
know 10 plus 10 plus 10 and then minus 0
minus 0 which is why you end up with a
30 over there now if you plot this
rightmost matrix as an image it will
look like that where there's this
lighter region right in the middle and
that corresponds to is having detected
this vertical edge down the middle of
your 6x6 image and in case the
dimensions here seem a little bit wrong
you know that the detected age seems
really thick that's only because we're
working with very small images in this
example and if you're using say a
thousand by a thousand image rather than
6 by 6 image then you find that this you
know does a pretty good job where the
detecting the edges the vertical edges
in your image and in this example this
bright region in the middle is just the
output images way of saying that it
looks like there's a strong vertical
edge right down the middle of the image
and maybe one intuition to take away
from vertical edge detection is that a
vertical edge is a 3 by 3 region since
we're using a 3 by 3 filter where there
are bright pixels on the left and you
don't care that much what's in the
middle
and dark pixels on the right right and
the middle of the image is really in the
six by six image is really where you
know there could be bright pixels on the
left and darker pixels on the right and
that's why it thinks as a vertical edge
over there and the convolution operation
gives you a convenient way to specify
how to find these vertical edges in an
image so you've now seen how the
convolution operator works in the next
video you see how to take this and use
it as one of the basic building blocks
of a composition on your network